hello everyone a while ago i made a
video called let's have some fun where I
said that I would line up all the pool
balls on the table and everybody can
pick a color pick a ball and if I sunk
that ball you get a free one of my zoo
good guide to help you grow your
business so today is the day I'm filming
that we got our list of people who
entered and we're going to see if I can
hopefully sink at least one ball from
the brain so i'm going to set up and
we'll see who wins here we go one
nothing okay we gonna do this again okay
I sunk the white ball that means that
our winner is Nina who bet against me
and said that I would sink the white
ball Nina already has the guide so that
doesn't count so we have to do it again
third time
nothing
four times solid blue
the first time I son white which was in
the right answer because only need about
it for that so the winner is solid blue
number two got it in the hole and so
Nina is gonna announce our winner and
she just happens to be all in blue today
so she's the good luck charm who is our
winner Nina so the winner is Herman
Herman Herman Hermanson all right okay
so congratulations Herman send me a note
and I'll hook you up with the complete
package of our sukkah guys for
entrepreneurs and if you guys have tips
for how I might be able to break better
than that and I think four times a
sinker ball leave in the comments below
thank you guys so much i must see you
soon